Vsauce Kevin here it's spring cycle
learn time spring fever is not listed
under real diagnostic medical category
but is often associated with increased
birth rates and the lifting of winter
depression however its original
connotation may have literally been with
actual sickness it said American
colonists coined the term to describe
weakness and fatigue after months
without fruits and vegetables symptoms
attributed to scurvy an advanced symptom
of the condition which peaked during
spring being fever the cycle of seasons
from winter to spring is marked by the
vernal equinox the day when the Earth's
axis is pointed parallel to the Sun
making day and night close to equal but
not exactly equal because the sun's rays
are bent by the Earth's atmosphere so we
can actually see the Sun before it rises
and after it sets if we lived in a world
without air then the equinox would truly
be an equal night the singing of winter
birds like chickadees and mocking birds
is one of the earliest signs of spring
but baby birds need to learn how to sing
like human infants they start out
babbling before learning to string
together different words correctly baby
birds raised by humans are often unable
to sing as adults but can learn from
hearing recordings of adult birds of the
same species the reason for daylight
saving time is to make better use of
daylight and it was first suggested by
Benjamin Franklin London builder William
Willett spent a fortune advocating for
it because he noticed people wouldn't
wake up earlier to use the daylight but
could take advantage of it in the
evening despite being controversial with
people like farmers who wake at dawn it
was enacted as law by governments to
save energy during World War 1 and again
in World War two in which a year-round
daylight saving time in the US was
called war time which equals spring
clean time spring cleaning has deep
roots around the world including
middle-eastern tradition where it's
thought to bring vibrancy to the new
year Jewish tradition where every single
crumb of unleavened bread must be
before Passover and in Chinese tradition
as a means of removing this fortune that
may have accumulated during the year
scientifically in cold winter climates
the air is dry which leads to dry skin
for you and your pets which leads to
flaking and therefore more dust building
up in your home that has closed windows
and doors so once it's warm enough to
open those up it's time for spring
cleaning and as always thanks for
watching
you